with the ability to conjure an enormous
ice palace in just seconds cause an
eternal winter and even create sentient
life Elsa was already an incredibly
powered character but in frozen to the
icy Queens legendary powers are taken to
another level when she hears a
mysterious voice calling to her and she
and Anna go on an epic quest to discover
the origin of her magical abilities
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
in this video I'll be explaining all of
Elsa's new powers in frozen - and the
secret truth about where her abilities
came from and if you'd like a chance to
win a cool frozen - Funko pop be sure to
subscribe and keep watching for more
details there will of course be spoilers
for the movie so take care if you
haven't seen it yet
by the end of frozen Elsa had learned to
control her magical ice abilities and
over the next three years her powers
mature with her
however the ice queen still harbours
questions about the origin of her powers
as frozen - begins we find that Elsa
still doesn't quite feel at ease with
herself and she loses control
occasionally accidentally freezing
objects when she gets distracted and is
surprised in a similar way to what
happened when she was younger
although the amount of ice has grown as
Elsa's powers have become stronger
what's distracting Elsa as a mysterious
voice that only she can hear you've been
hearing a voice and you didn't think to
tell me and one night when Elsa decides
to answer the call we see her magic
begin to create some new and exciting I
see visions frozen - director Jennifer
Lee has explained that during Elsa song
into the unknown the voice is showing
Elsa pieces of the past and also what
her magic could be the movies animators
have also said that while its Elsa's
magic it seems to be taken over by these
I see visions she's not necessarily
controlling it if you watch the scene
carefully you'll notice Elsa's ice magic
creates visions of what's to come later
in the movie such as her parting the
mist to the enchanted forest
the trees inside the forest reindeer
running around visions of her young
mother and father encounters with the
four spirits and then Elsa's stepping
inside at a Harlan and becoming the
fifth spirit Elsa's magic together with
the voice is giving her a sense of
foresight into her future as Elsa
continues her exploration of these new
powers the voice from the north course
to her creating a sudden burst of
crystals over arendelle Elsa sees that
inside the crystals are symbols which
represent the four elements these same
four symbols also show up on the
monoliths at the entrance to the
enchanted forest and it's inside the
forest where Elsa's powers help her
access hidden details about the past
when the Ganga swirled up in a tornado
by the wind spirit Gale Elsa is able to
direct powerful blasts of ice that
freeze the wind still and Elsa's icy
blasts are also able to freeze water
droplets in the air and reform them into
sculptures of events that happened years
ago in the forest as Olaf theory goes
water retains memory so Elsa's ice magic
is able to reveal that Elsa and Ana's
parents met each other when they were
children in the forest once Elsa
understands this new power when she
discovers the wreck of their parent ship
she's able to extract water droplets
that have remained soaked in the wooden
panels of the ship and freeze them into
a tragic icy vision of what happened to
their mother and father Elsa's abilities
even extend to conjuring up the voices
of their parents just before they died
in the storm inside the forest we also
get to see Elsa's link to two of the
other elemental spirits when Bruni the
salamander fire Spirit sets the forest
trees on fire it's Elsa who not only
puts out the flames but who is also able
to face the fiery little spirit creature
and make a connection with him although
he burns hot on her hands she's able to
calm him down with little snowflakes
that he loves to feel on his tongue he
can hear the voice at course to Elsa and
helps guide her north towards it and I
know what that means
frozen tooth animators have also said
that Bruni is misunderstood and Elsa can
relate to that as they've both had
problems with their powers running wild
and getting out of control
Elsa is also connected to the earth
Giants and when they come roaming near
their camp in the forest she's actually
a little more excited than scurred she
later explains to honor that the Giants
sensed her and came looking for her
proving Elsa's connection to another of
the four elements during her time in the
forest
Elsa also learns from honey Maren that
there's a fifth spirit said to be a
bridge between people and the magic of
nature and that only utter Harlan can
provide an answer to who or what the
fifth spirit is to reach at a Harlan
Elsa must face her most difficult
challenge crossing the extremely
dangerous dark sea the same water that
took the life of her parents when they
tried to sell through it Elsa's
confidence and ability to concentrate on
focus her powers has grown tremendously
by this point and she begins by freezing
a huge pathway through the waves with an
enormous blast of ice the Titanic waves
are still too much though and smashed
the pathway into huge chunks of ice
taking Elsa underwater where she's
confronted by the water spirit which
takes the form of a powerful stallion
this is a mythical creature fraud ich
folklore and is a fierce warrior and
guardian that only allows past those it
deems worthy of its respect in the myths
it often tries to drown challenges which
is exactly what it tries to do to Elsa
however she eventually proves herself an
equal match to the water spirit when she
uses a barrage of ice powers to protect
herself and as she does with the Wind
and Fire spirits Elsa was able to tame
the water spirit this time by creating
an icy lassi which she uses to mount the
horse after she rides the stallion to
the frozen river after Harlan they bow
to each other showing that Elsa has
earned the respect of this fearsome
spirit by proving herself worthy Elsa's
arrival at out of Harlan symbolically
represents her arriving home to embrace
her true nature and all of her powers as
the lyrics of her songs show yourself
proof I'm arriving and it feels like I
am home as Elsa arrived she lets her
hair flow loose out of the constraints
of her braids a moment that recalls how
she let her hair down during letting
in the first movie and the feelings of
shame and guilt about her powers which
she's repressed as she grew up conceal
it don't fear it and now tossed aside as
she gleefully runs through the glaciers
tunnels and cabins leaping across chasms
and tossing huge ice columns aside when
Elsa reaches a cavern with symbols of
the four spirits she uses her magic to
bring these together around a four-sided
star and symbol of unity and Elsa now is
revealed as the fifth spirit after
uniting herself in spirit without a
Harlan Elsa is now able to read the
secret memories of the past contained
within the frozen river she begins to
see memories of events from her past
including snuggling with her mother
marshmallow
she showed as it herself singing let it
go and sees villains like the Duke of
weselton and Hans and as she goes deeper
into the glacier she uncovers the
shameful treachery of her grandfather
when he secretly betrayed and attacked
the North Andhra people as powerful as a
fifth spirit is Elsa is still vulnerable
and as a lullaby all is found warned
Elsa's guilted uncovering this dark
history of one of her ancestors proves
too much Elsa literally freezes as she
discovers each new piece of the
arendelle Ian deceit until she's
overcome and loses control entirely and
this is where Elsa's connection back to
Anna proves vital to our eventual
survival remember that Anna talked about
two sisters one mind when playing
charades with Elsa and the gang at the
beginning of the movie honey Maren also
told Elsa that the fifth spirit is a
bridge between worlds and as Elsa later
points out a bridge has two sides in
honor is the other side of that bridge
Elsa realizes this and with her powers
she sends a ray of ice magic to the cave
were honor and Olaf a sheltering the
magic forms a sculpture that tells honor
about the truth about their grandfather
it's only when Anna continues on despite
the loss of her sister and Olaf and
destroys the dam that arendelle's wrong
against the north Audra can finally be
righted an act which also liberates and
saves Elsa from her icy doom 120
without you he'll always have me in fact
grandpoppy also foreshadowed that honor
would be needed to save Elsa from her
fate without you she may lose yourself
to it with Elsa free we finally get to
witness the full extent of her powers as
a fifth spirit she's able to call on the
water spirit and ride it at incredible
speed to arendelle where she throws up
an enormous ice wall which has the
shapes of the four elements and the
fifth spirit on it the wall blocks the
deluge of water that's about to engulf
the kingdom and then Elsa raises her
arms and with the force of her magic she
blasts the ice wall in terms of water to
flow away from arendelle unlike the
moment when the crystals appeared at the
end of into the unknown
this time Elsa is in full control and
this new power level calls back to
Grandpa V's words we have always feared
Elsa's powers were too much for this
world now we must pray they are enough
as the fifth spirit also has power to
summon all four spirits and this is
reflected in the design of her final
white dress which has motifs of all of
the four elemental symbols and it's also
represented in the unity necklace that
Elsa whirls around her neck
Elsa also seems to have the power of
Resurrection although her rebirth
appears to be a gift from the spirits
that reward honors act of heroism in
restoring balance to the world by
destroying the arendelle Ian damn given
Elsa's almost godlike powers that we see
at the end of frozen - it will be
fascinating to see how a future story
could take these forward any potential
villains would need to be either
particularly powerful or able to strike
at some hidden weakness in Elsa either a
new one or something we've seen such as
her feelings of guilt about the past
which caused her to freeze while in Atta
Harlan fans of other mythic and epic
fictional characters may also compare
else's power levels with Gandalf the
white from Lord of the Rings the avatar
from The Last Airbender and Lilu from
The Fifth Element
Atta Harlan may be the source of Elsa's
powers but a question of scene from a
lot of you is why was else are born with
magical powers the answer seems to be
that they are a gift from the spirits
after fighting broke out between the
arendelle Ian's and the North Andhra
people
Elsa's mother Adina saved ignores life
as our
explains to Elsa because if Dunas saved
her enemy her good deed was rewarded
with a magical daughter and as Elsa
learns the star-shaped symbol she sees
in the sky is the same as the pattern on
the shawl that Queen Adina gave Elsa and
Anna when they were children
establishing both the sisters and
mothers connection with the four spirits
so what do you think about Elsa's new
powers in frozen 2 and do you have any
theories or ideas on how she could use
them in future frozen stories share your
thoughts in the comments and don't
forget to subscribe and hit the gleam
link below for a chance to win an
awesome frozen - Funko pop next tap left
for another frozen - video or tap right
for something else you're sure to LIKE
and if you enjoyed this than a thumbs up
and a share are hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers